The ethical dilemma I've always
struggled with in my career as a writer
is that,
um,
I tend to like the people that I write
about and I,
I believe it's my duty and job as a
writer to empathize with my subject.
Uh,
not to get too high flow Dostoyevsky's
said,
um,
it's very easy to condemn the evildoer.
Um,
but the challenge is to understand him
or her.
That's what I'm always trying to do.
Um,
and um,
I,
I sometimes end up favoring my subjects
too much.
Um,
and then I have to be stern with myself
and say,
ethically it's my job to dig out the
nasty truths and to tell them as well.
So,
um,
that's what I tried to do.
I almost invariably fall out of favor
with the people I write about.
Um,
my first book on Saudi Arabia was
banned.
Um,
I am told this new book I've just
written on Saudi Arabia will be banned.
Um,
one of my most successful books,
I went to live in Detroit,
Michigan and wrote about the Ford
family.
And that was a wonderful experience to
sort of live in a big old grimey
American city.
Although I could send them mentally
afford to say that because I was going
to go away and I didn't have to live
with the problems of the rust belt.
Um,
I thought I painted a wonderfully
sympathetic portrait of the Ford family,
but they haven't spoken to me from that
day to this.
Um,
and I can live with that.
That's,
you know,
that's part of the,
the job of being a writer.
Um,
there's a falseness to it.
You know,
you,
you meet someone,
you creator,
I'm,
you genuinely like them,
but there's an element of facsimile in
the friendship that you are creating
because it's going to end the moment.
Um,
the,
the interview is over and you have to
under,
you know,
realistically,
um,
I interview people to get something out
of them and they give me interviews
because they want something out of me
weed.
And,
um,
does that bargain and compromise in,
in every transaction that a writer or
journalist charism.